how lovely I can tell you're a lovely
audience already very warm welcome to
you all thank you very much
Hanna we are going to be debating a
motion tonight hoping it's going to be
very lively even without our two MPs but
they are going to come the motion is the
left has right on its side politics
there's an awful lot of it's about isn't
there now what side you're on on the
political spectrum tells us a great deal
about your vision for society how you
think society ought to be
but are you willing to have your mind
changed let's see if that happens today
you've already voted on the motion as
you came in shortly we're going to be
hearing the opening speeches of our
speakers and then I'm going to announce
the results of that first vote we'll be
taking questions from you and
encouraging some lively debate I hope
between the speakers the speakers will
then close their debate with a short
summing up and then we'll have the final
vote and you will have one of those and
how you vote there'll be ushers running
around at the point at which you are
going to be voting and just tear the
slip on that you want to vote with and
put it into the box and if you still
haven't made up your mind don't tear
anything and put the whole slip in now
if you're on the left do you believe
that people who share your worldview are
the ones who have society's best
interests at heart that your perspective
your compassion for those who are weaker
less robust members of society are
better protected by your vision and your
view of the world is it the left the
only that will fight for sexual racial
equality for the rights of workers is it
you on the Left who think that your view
of the world will ultimately make it a
better place for the largest numbers
possible
but if you identify yourself as a person
on the right do you feel that at the
heart of the view that I've just
outlined very briefly there is hypocrisy
that just because you say that you care
that you have more compassion that it
makes you right because you display your
compassion the left according to some on
the right many on the right feel that in
fact that view is damaging to the state
that expanding the state and intervening
to help those people who are less robust
can in fact be counterproductive and
therefore allowing those people who
might be instinctively individual and
want to use their entrepreneurial spirit
to better themselves are actually being
stifled in some way I'm going to
introduce our opening speaker George mom
Bo columnist for The Guardian known of
course for his political and
environmental activism he has several
best-selling books to his name captive
states the corporate takeover of Britain
and most recently out of the wreckage a
new politics for an age of crisis George
is going to be speaking for demotion
thank you all thanks very much rezian um
I have to confess before I begin that
the left sometimes drive me round the
bend the meetings the factions the
endless splitting it's true to say
unfortunately that the old adage often
holds up that the right seeks converts
and the left seeks traitors and there
will be a public guillotine of opposing
factions at the end of this debate but
for all that I am on the Left I belong
to the left and I will remain on the
left because the left is the only
solution to a predicament that faces
every generation and this predicament is
the escalating concentration of wealth
and power this happens not because
people are wicked though there are one
or two it is an innate and intrinsic
characteristic of all complex societies
going all the way back to the first
cities in Mesopotamia 6,000 or more
years ago and it happens well perhaps a
good way of explaining how and why this
happens is through the concept that
Thomas Piketty
has popularized of patrimonial capital
what he shows very convincingly in my
view is that when the rate of return to
capital exceeds the rate of growth of
economic output then necessarily
inevitably inequality spirals social
mobility stalls and an enterprise
society gives way to a runty a society
now to put this in more comprehensible
terms if you have a lot of money and
property you can use that money on
property to extract more money and
property from the rest of society in the
form of economic rent now I define
economic rent as being the excessive
charges that you can impose on people
for the use of non reproducible
resources over which you have
exclusive control a good example is the
ridiculous cost of rail tickets which we
have to pay because the rail companies
have us over a barrel so they can charge
us way above what the rate ought to be
because we have no choice but to use
their service if we want to travel from
one place to another that's an example
of economic rent now the accumulation of
this wealth and power that arises from
those returns to capital this this is
something with no natural limit there's
no point at which it stops itself except
sometimes through economic collapse but
if there is no political or position to
that accumulation it grows and grows
until as we've seen in several periods
of history a very small number of people
managed to capture just about all the
production of society and sometimes the
result of that is that the destitution
and debt and unemployment that that
tremendous capture of social wealth
causes will then lead to that economic
implosion of the kind that we saw for
instance with the Great Depression now
it doesn't end there because once you've
managed to capture a great deal of
economic power you can use their
economic power to capture political
power and everywhere where we see that
sort of unalloyed growth of tremendous
economic concentration we see a
concentration of political power going
alongside it democracy becomes more or
less a dead-letter the whole concept of
a popular government is undermined and
we end up with government of the elite
by the elite for the elite does this
sound at all familiar to anyone it's
it's a sort of inexorable development of
not having sufficient opposition to that
vicious cycle of growing concentration
of wealth and power
let me give you an example of how this
operates if we look back to the second
half of the 19th century and we can take
the example of one form of economic rent
which is the excessive fees that you
must pay to rent a place to live and an
extreme example was the old nickel which
was a slum developed in the second half
of the nineteenth century around Bethnal
Green there were people living in that
slum who occupied a single room a whole
family occupying a single room in a
cellar five foot high with no natural
light there are hundreds of people
living in those conditions and thousands
living in conditions which was scarcely
better the rate of infant mortality was
roughly twice that of society as a whole
because most of those families could
only afford one bed and the whole family
slept in one bed and one of the causes
of that mortality was that people would
roll over in the night and suffocate the
babies the rooms were infested with damp
with rats with lice with fleas with
rotting walls with collapsing ceilings
because the people who owned these
buildings invested nothing at all in
repairing them they didn't need to
people had no choice but to live there
and to pay and yet despite those
conditions people in the old nickel were
paying per cubic foot four times as much
as tenants of the poshest houses in the
West End
why were they paying this extraordinary
fees for these disgusting conditions
well because they had no power whereas
the landlord's power over them was
almost absolute in order to try to raise
that money those people in the old
Nicolle worked every hour that they
could every waking hour basically they
were working in their own rooms in often
appalling conditions doing piecework
being paid very little for it such that
for the inhabitants of the old
called the name they gave it was the
sweaters hell but the people who
harvested this money these extraordinary
rents that the people were paying they
didn't have to work at all these people
included MPs peers of the realm senior
churchmen some of them became among some
richest people in the country they
didn't even have to collect the rents
they sent their agents to do that often
with great brutality and that process
basically inexorably led to the
accumulation and accumulation of wealth
until we saw its explosion there the
explosion of the whole system later in
in the early 20th century with the Great
Depression so who's going to stop that
from happening
well not the right because the right
basically exists to protect patrimonial
capital that is what it's there for
where's the left when it remembers what
it's for exists to try to break the
power of patrimonial capital and to
break that vicious cycle of accumulation
on the one side and deprivation on the
other now I know that the days of the
old nickel have for the time being
passed but let's see roughly where we're
placed on this index I wonder if you
could help me with this um could anyone
who rents please put their hands up
thank you could you keep your hand I'm
sorry to keep your hands up for now but
could you put your hands down if you pay
less than 25% of your income in rent so
in other words if you pay 25% or more
keep your hands up 40% or more anyone
here pay 50% 1 or 2 now in 1885 in
response to the old nickel scandal and
others the Royal Commission on the
housing of the working classes reported
that there were several well quite a few
almost half the people in the working
class were paying 25 percent or more of
their income in rent today we find
ourselves back in a similar position
we haven't yet descended to the
conditions of the old nickel principally
I believe because we're still enjoying
the legacy of the Social Democratic era
a period when the Left managed to get a
foothold in British politics that's a
legacy which is gradually fading it's
sort of more or less came to an end that
here are about 40 years ago but we still
I believe benefit from it and at times
the left was highly effective at
breaking the vicious cycle that I'm
talking about so for example in the
1940s when the left was perhaps at the
height of its power in the United States
the top rates of income tax rose to 94
percent in the United Kingdom to 98
percent an economist look back to that
period and say well that was completely
irrational because the Laffer curve
shows that beyond about seventy percent
you get no greater revenue back from
your income tax but they're missing the
point of it because those very high
rates of tax were not just to raise
revenue they were to break the power of
patrimonial capital and they did so with
great effect such that for the first
time in history working-class people in
this country had decent housing often in
the form of housing provided by the
state council housing we got the NHS we
got very high employment with a
widespread distribution of prosperity
and well-being we got a robust social
safety net which prevented anyone from
falling to the condition of people in
the old nickel in the previous century
these were astonishing achievements but
they could only be brought about through
breaking that vicious cycle and
redistributing wealth
unfortunately when Margaret Thatcher and
Ronald Reagan came to power they began
to reverse a lot of that they brought
the top rates of tax right down and they
laid waste to
public protections to regulations
intended to defend people from predatory
behavior in amongst those regulations
were rent controls and so the vicious
circle began to turn again and Tony
Blair and Gordon Brown there were 13
years of labor politics here but they
didn't really grasp the importance of
that power of patrimonial capital and
the importance of trying to contain it
so even through those years that
inequality and that escalation of the
concentration of wealth and power
continued to develop and have continued
since so who is going to break this
who's going to break the circle who's
going to ensure that we don't end up
with a tiny number of people taking the
majority of social wealth into their own
hands I mean it's happening already
Piketty and Saez showed that in the
first term of Obama's Obama's first term
in office the 1% took 94 percent of all
the economic growth in those first four
years 94 percent of it went into the
hands of the 1% this is very this is
very close to approaching the point at
which a tiny faction manages to capture
the whole production of society and
that's a very dangerous point indeed not
just for people on the losing end of
that but for the whole social and
economic structure which then is pushed
gradually towards collapse we've seen
rumbles of that with the 2008 financial
crisis but I suggest we've seen nothing
at that we've seen we've seen nothing so
far by comparison to what it could
become
so who is going to break this history to
may going to break the vicious cycle I
don't think so is the conservative party
going to break the British the vicious
cycle I don't think so it exists
effectively to sustain it to protect and
insulate the winners of that process
from challenge only the left
can do it only the left has ever done it
only the left for all its manifest and
manifold faults many of which I will
probably have to admit tonight will will
continue to do it and only when we have
a real left which really recognizes its
role as breaking that cycle will we see
this very dangerous trend going into
reverse so my friends I urge you please
to support the motion that though it's
not always right no one ever is by and
large broadly speaking the left has
right on its side thank you
Thank You George Monbiot our first
speaker for the motion
our first speaker against the motion is
Roger Scruton he has published more than
40 books on philosophy aesthetics and
politics including how to be a
conservative and fools frauds and
firebrands thinkers of the new left he
is Britain's leading philosopher of
conservative thought but by his own
admission he says there isn't much
competition Roger Scruton
please against the motion
thank you very much for that kind
introduction and thank you George for
that very powerful and rhetorical
presentation of the left-wing case as it
was in 1865 or there abouts but my own
feeling about this is that of course we
all in the end depend upon some story of
our history in order to bolster up
present attitudes and the left has been
very good at creating a kind of
mythopoeic history of our country which
leaves out of consideration all the
things that particularly appeal to me my
father's family rose from the slums in
Manchester not through the help of the
socialist state but because my
grandmother had a mortgage with the
Building Society the local friendly
Society which was founded in fact a
hundred years before by the
working-class people of Manchester in
order to offer each other mutual aid
that was one of the ways in which people
advanced in that in our society in those
times they had difficulties with health
but they already enjoyed before the
National Health Service the kind of
treatment that made it possible to
survive the epidemics of tuberculosis
and so on that existed inevitably
because of the sanitary conditions of
the new newly built cities and that was
played possible by the British Medical
Association which was a voluntary
Association of doctors beginning in 1834
and the network of hospitals that they
founded that network of course made it
possible for the National Health to
exist but it existed long before the
states took charge of it and I think we
should remember that that our country
has enjoyed a great deal of charitable
work which has alleviated much of the
oppression that George rightly refers to
the question really in my mind is to
what extent do we go along with this
myth that capital that that the right
exists to protect capital and if the
left exists to break it down and
redistribute it among those who who
deserve it I think that this vision is
not exactly paranoid but but that
history has moved on since the time when
that vision was plausible it is true as
he says that Thomas Piketty has argued
that always there'll be more and more
concentration of capital in the hands of
the few but the real question that I
would propose is whether that means that
there is none in the hands of the many
it all depends upon the quantity of it
and the institutions which permit the
expenditure of it and its distribution
at a certain time in my life I used to
travel around Eastern Europe which was a
then a socialist and clav under the
control of the Soviet Union and at the
same time being an academic I would
travel to America too so I had the
opportunity to compare two very
different systems one calling itself
socialist the other called by those who
opposed it capitalist luckily Americans
don't use these nineteenth-century terms
but the thing that was most visible to
me at least was not that just that there
was much less wealth in Eastern Europe
than in America but also that it was not
widely distributed and that the
distinctions between those who who had
control of it and those who didn't were
largely political depended whether you
were a member of the party or not
whether you were part of the Socialist
machine and if you are not part of a
socialist machine not only were you
deprived of property you certainly do
weren't able to buy a house or sell
things like property in an open market
but you are also deprived of elementary
freedoms such as the freedom to say the
kind of things I'm saying
now one of the things that I feel that
we should we on the right should
emphasize is that politics is not just
about the distribution of wealth it's
not just about the what George has just
been telling us about even though that
is terribly important there are other
things that matter too and these other
things were visible then in America the
freedom of people to get a go about
their daily life
the social mobility that enabled you to
change class or the kind of the social
mobility that that George has enjoyed in
falling to the state that he is in and
that I have enjoyed in race rising to
mine and these these things these
features were not present in the
socialist countries in those days when
socialism really had something going for
it and I feel that we ought to look at
the the rest of politics to see exactly
what it is therefore the right should be
defending if you're on the Left you tend
to have a cause George is very good with
causes the environmental cause which
he's been about which I agree with him
entirely he has a causes such as his
present one about the distribution of
property and the abolition of the ranty
a class about which I'm net less
enthusiastic but having causes is very
consoling sort of thing you can say
forward you've got this clenched fist
salute is always there ready to go and
people will gather behind you for me
conservatism can't be concentrated into
a slogan in that way it is it isn't a
matter of gathering behind the clenched
fist salute or if it did the slogan will
be something like hesitate you know
which of course doesn't naturally
recruit a following
and I what I would want to say that and
having said that it's let's look around
at the actual world the world that we
have and see what we can love in it and
what we are attached to and surely we
should be defending those things and
seeing how it precious they have been to
us and out of that vision or comes
another kind of politics one which is
not just obsessed with wealth in its
distribution but which recognizes the
great benefits that we've inherited in
particular the benefit of freedom under
law which is something which I think in
many parts of the world just does not
exist the freedom to have a debate like
this the freedom to start up an
enterprise of one's own to think of
one's whole life anew and begin again
the autonomy of the individual the right
to own something and to exchange that
thing okay people have had difficulties
in owning property in this country but
I'm sure most people in this room those
who did not put up their hand about to
confess that they were renting something
are quite proud to own something and
regard it as a freedom because they can
exchange it for something else we should
remember that we belong to a civil
society defined by a shared royalty and
this makes it possible for us to live
under a political process I'm because of
the loyalty that binds us all together
as citizens of this country we can
accept to be governed by people whom we
hate
I can accept to be governed by Jorge for
instance I don't hate Jorge but but
worthy to be there in Parliament and
maybe Prime Minister one day I would be
deeply upset but nevertheless my view
the matter would be that I'm it that I'm
under an obligation to obey the law and
to and to live peaceably in this in that
jurisdiction we have a culture that that
affirms these institutions and affirms
that the importance of civil society
over the state and we have the freedom
to build new institutions
from private private institutions of our
own and this is terribly important in
education when George spoke about the
ranty a state the rent he was a class he
forgot that there is also the rent a
state there is a there are institutions
in our society which are more or less
absorbed into the state the education
system being one of them and of course
the National Health Service another and
these aren't necessarily the kind of
things which I think the people of this
country are well served by if you look
at the universities today these are
centers of privilege in which people are
protected largely from the surrounding
economic order and from the any
opposition to their own particular
standing and they are dominated by
people like George
luckily he is not part of a university
just as I am NOT but it is the case that
in my case I'm not part of a university
because I could never now go back into
one I have the wrong point of view and
this the dominance of the left in those
state controlled institutions is now an
immovable part of our society and I
think it's one of the things that people
on the right object to it's a natural
tendency on the left to think that your
opponent is not wrong but evil and
therefore you're justified in excluding
him from any office and I think this is
something that we've seen growing in
recent years but however many people on
the Left share my kind of aspirations to
aspirations towards a free society of
creative institutions and and I think
that that's the kind of left that I
would like to see emerging but he will
only emerge if we forget this obsession
with property and its distribution and
look back at our inheritance and the
great gift that it is to us that we can
enjoy it and stand side-by-side even in
our disagreements and recognize that we
have a shared loyalty
much of the left today has been flow
focused on attacking that loyalty
attacking the nation-state in favor of
some kind of cosmopolitan government
attacking our national culture including
its religious roots in favor of
multiculturalism attacking independent
initiatives in education and healthcare
and the rest in favor of state
supervised
initiatives which lead to the
perpetuation of the of the status quo
and there has been this mass hostility
on the left to something called
neoliberalism the habit of marketing
everything and now if there is such a
thing as neoliberalism and that's what
it is I'm against it too but my own view
is that that's not what the right is all
about the right is about the maintenance
of an old fashioned civil patriotism and
the bourgeois way of life that goes with
it
and that's the kind of thing that I
think we that I would like to defend in
opposing this motion and saying that
indeed the left might think itself to be
on the right about everything but it is
just as much in the wrong now as it's
always been
Roger Scruton thank you very much indeed
and as you've all just noticed quasi
Quarton Conservative MP for Spelthorne
has just joined us welcome thank you
very much for being with us
I just before since we don't have
Selleck Ricci and she would have been
the next person to speak for the motion
I'm I'm just going to I wonder whether
we yeah I think we should probably just
go to you quazy and even though it's not
the right way round of doing it I think
that's what we're going to do so if
you've caught your breath good would you
like to go to the podium and I will just
introduce you again MP for Spelthorne of
course has worked as a financial analyst
and journalist and historian and he also
has books to add to his success
ghosts of empire Britain's legacies in
the modern world and Thatcher's trial
six months that defined a leader quasi
is also going to speak against the
motion thank you very much for your
introduction I've just
I would just like to say and apologize
obviously for being late we've had to
vote in the House of Commons against lay
the Labour Party against socialists or
some of them were socialists anyway and
I have to apologize for not hearing
George's speech in its entirety I've
read his columns for 20 years so I
probably imagine I've got a good idea
what he said but I won't try and
recapture his spirit or try and marshal
my arguments against theses that I
didn't hear his arguments that I haven't
heard but what I will do in my short
allotted time is recapitulate on some of
the things that Roger said I didn't
agree actually
with everything that Roger said but the
great thing about being on the right is
that we don't have to have a universal
agreement on everything there is no ten
commandments or holy text which we have
to subscribe to on pain of death and I
know that hasn't quite the Labour Party
and the Corbyn hasn't quite reached that
point yet but but Roger did allude to a
uniformity of view a climate of fear
almost that many people on the Left feel
particularly today I mean you only have
to go to universities as I have done to
see this notion of no platforming now I
don't consider myself very old but I
don't remember at university in the
1990s ever hearing of such a phrase as
no platforming and that's the kind of
culture that we have today and I think
it's deeply worrying and I think it's
actually just strangles free speech it
inhibits creative discourse it
frustrates debate and it's not the way I
think a modern society should be
evolving now in terms of socialism I am
going to have two arguments one I think
is based on theory and if you look at
what people like Karl Marx who is the
probably the most widely read thinker of
the left probably certainly the most
influential historically and I think
even today one of one of certainly the
most influential left-wing thinkers and
look at history look at examples and
you're not even looking at it
looking at the present across the world
you see socialism failing miserably to
to deliver now people say we love the
left what is the left I think the left
is very much something which as we know
came out of the French Revolution but
it's our type of thinker was Karl Marx
and the problem that Karl Marx had was
that all the prophecies that he made
about kaif ISM were wrong
he was a great analytical thinker and if
you read his work in 1867 I think when
capital the first volume of capital came
out you would be forgiven for thinking
that he'd solved the problem of
modernity had solved the problem of
industrial society and that capitalism
indeed would collapse under the weight
of its own contradictions and that the
capitalist class would drive the poor
drive the proletariat to such a pitch of
misery that they would rebel and
overthrow their their exploiters now
that in 1867 I would say was not a bad
prognosis not it not it not a senseless
prediction but what happened what
happened was that over the last hundred
and fifty years capitalism and here I do
slightly differ with Roger and he might
call it near liberalism but capitalism
has liberated millions upon millions of
people even in the last twenty years it
has lifted something like a billion
people out of poverty it is a complete
fallacy for the left to say that more
people are miserable and poor today than
has ever been the case that's the
opposite of the truth and Karl Marx
could never have dreamt of the successes
of of capitalism broadly speaking I
would say liberalism at anything is
anything new about it I think liberalism
is a perfectly adequate way of
describing the kind of order that are I
seek to describe and he was completely
wrong now if your central thinker
and the central premise of your ideology
has got predictions completely wrong I
think you have to question the drift and
nature of the ideology he is espoused so
in terms of theory
I think his theories have been more
broadly disproved by modern practice and
now you look at the actual instances the
examples of socialist left-wing
government you have an appalling
twentieth century I am NOT going to
mention what I could mention Stalin I
have mentioned Stalin there but that was
a cheap shot
I accept that was a cheap jaaye but you
know Stalin was a disciple of Karl Marx
he was someone who described himself as
being on the left and one of the
favorites of the modern Conservative
Party is to go on about Venezuela and
the electorate frankly is not interested
in Venezuela like totally understand why
they're not interested in Venezuela it's
a long way away and most of us have
never been there but it's still an
appalling situation in Venezuela it's
got a horrible plate it's a horrible
place to live the murder rate is
probably the highest bar Honduras in the
world it is a society which was the
richest country in Latin America in
South America and it is now a country
where people are being killed in order
to get some flour or in order to get a
bit of petrol there is a palling
lawlessness and the reason why that
country collapsed into the decay that it
did was because of socialism now people
will say well it wasn't proper socialism
and it wasn't properly interpreted but
it's a ghastly price for a country to
pay and North Korea is another example
and these are people who ostensibly
preach socialism they're on the Left
they're people who subscribe to Marxist
ideology and these are palling instances
and not something which I think should
be lightly brushed aside one person
who's not very funny but it we made an
interesting observation he said that a
socialist government in the Sahara would
result in the government trying to
import
sound within three years and that's the
kind of paradox that socialism can often
lead to and I'm not going to wax as
eloquently as Roger did about freedom
ordered freedom the rule of law
tradition and all those things we know
where the left stands on these things
and we know that an extreme left-wing
government would destroy much of the
world the country that we know now I
think that I understand the appeal of
socialism I understand in what is a
seemingly a chaotic world people wanting
certainty and wanting a degree of
clarity but I don't think that socialism
I don't think the left has any answers
to provide on that subject I think the
left is an old-fashioned ideology I'm
struck by the fact that many of the
people who are its supporters now
prominent politicians are people who
first went into politics in the 1970s
and it seems striking to me when I
listen to some of these I would mention
them but we know who they are I feel
that I've gone back 40 years to the age
of two years old not that I understood
socialism when I was two but I could
imagine that people watching television
in 1977 would see many of the same ideas
that have been trotted out now expounded
then forcefully I would say even more
eloquently by people like Tony Benn
Michael Mitra and Michael foot we've
heard the arguments before and I think
today those arguments are just as
invalid and wrong as they were 40 years
ago so the conclusion is the left was
never right that's my conclusion
Kwasi Quarton thank you very much indeed
still no sign of Stella Creasy as soon
as she does arrive we will give her the
opportunity to speak for the motion
before I open up the questions to the
floor I can I can now bring you the pre
vote so you all voted when you came in
before you'd even heard any of the
speakers and we have 37% voting against
the motion thirty two four and thirty
one undecided it's quite a lot of
undecideds that's interesting so keep
those figures in your head and we're
going to open up the questions to the
floor there are people walking around
with microphones and I'm going to take
two or three questions at a time so uh
sure number one if you could take the my
friend microphone to the first speaker
if you can confine yourself to short
questions and not long statements that
would be brilliant thank you thank you I
teach and as a teacher I have to
recognize the worth of of all my
students and I have to let go of my
baggage and one of the things that both
parties have going for them is a lot of
baggage so I'd ask both Georgia and more
specifically Roger
when will the left let go of its baggage
around anti-semitism and on Roger
when will the right let go of its
homophobia and when will either party
show the moral courage to welcome child
refugees into this country thank you
let's have another question before we we
put those points to there's a woman here
at the front if we could okay so uh sure
number three lovely I just like to ask
Roger you mentioned that the motto of
the Conservatives should be hesitate
does the right therefore exists only to
mitigate the left
thank you very much and question down
here I think you got the microphone yes
how would you argue the case of Germany
pre the Berlin Wall falling that surely
if your proposition is correct it would
have been the other way everyone would
been fleeing across the water East
Germany and we would see it as a great
social democracy now rather than the
well generally successful possibly not
this week state thank thank you very
much Roger would you like to take some
some of those on so we've got when will
the left
when will the right allow for her
mistake the existence of homosexuality
let's deal with that one first and then
does the right only exists to mitigate
the left yeah well I'm one of the those
people who was brought up in the 60s I
went to Cambridge where my my principal
faults were being lower class right-wing
and heterosexual I had real trouble on
those three grounds there was no way of
getting on in Cambridge society without
hiding those defects so I did so I got
used to the whole culture that there
prevailed and the whole idea that
somehow people like me were homophobic
came as an enormous shock where when
this ridiculous word got invented you
know I said well you know what on earth
have I done and what what have
conservatives like me like me done and
particularly all the right wing friends
that I had at Cambridge were you know
straightforwardly gay or queer I mean in
all the meanings of that word and the
queerest thing about them was that they
were right wing
so I would say that they may be that
some people on the right have to reject
this to drop this baggage but I've never
picked it up it's an interesting
personal response but I wonder if you
would take on the issue of of the party
politics of it because clearly the right
does present itself as quite moralistic
it does present itself as as the
ideology of the you know of the the
family and so on so I'm a believer in
the family I also think we believe in
the normality of the heterosexual Union
and the need to the sexes to make
sacrifices for each other I do recognize
that the legitimizing legitimation of
homosexuality has come about as a
necessary historical development and of
course people rightfully you feel that
this is a huge change to their family
values I prefer the family values it's
absolutely true but I don't go in around
in public making a fuss about it on the
thing about whether the right exists
only to mitigate the left this is a very
good observation that's absolutely true
we are non-political people who happen
to love our political inheritance
nevertheless and we're confronted with
all these urgent activists telling us
that there's something immoral about
that that inheritance and something that
we should be ashamed of so we're forced
to defend what actually we would prefer
people simply not to notice just like in
the family you know if you're forced to
defend the love that binds you to your
wife and children you will find that
your the whole family Order has been
upset
it should just exist George would you
like to respond first to the questions
in the audience and then react to what
Roger has said so let's do the only
issue of anti-semitism in live in a very
simple world that Rogers I have to
existing all the one that anyone
actually lives in at all anyway
yeah anti-semitism look I've got no
truck with this at all it's absolutely
outrageous I think Ken
Livingston should be booted as far as he
can be booted it's absolutely
disgraceful and as far as I'm concerned
anyone who claims to be on the left and
is an anti-semite has got no place on a
left that I recognized now I should say
that I'm not a member of the Labor Party
I'm you know I believe there are many
different left side belonged to what I
would call the sort of green democratic
rather Wooley left it's still
recognizably left but you know you don't
have to toe any particular party line to
call yourself a call yourself a left
winger obviously Stella does but you
know the idea that there should be any
such intolerance in a party that calls
itself left-wing you know it's been
blowing up a bit out of proportion but
when it's not blown up when it exists
for real
there should be no tolerance whatsoever
of anti-semitism or anything similar to
that on the idea of German Germany pre
pre war I mean obviously you're right no
I understand it so you're pre pre pre
the collapse of the wall oh you're quite
right of course and I've got no truck at
all with those communist regimes and no
truck with Stalinism again you don't
have to to be on the left you can be on
the left and think that Stalin was one
of the worst people ever to blot the
face of this planet and to think that
those regimes in Eastern Europe were at
a fright and a terror and a horror to
the people who lived under them but you
know we don't have to be like that the
left which we create in this country can
be entirely different to that and Rogers
conceit that it was a right who invented
freedom and the left to try to take it
away
I thought he I was the one who's
supposed to know nothing about history
has he forgotten the diggers and the
Levellers and the Chartists and the
suffragettes how many of those would you
place on the right freedom is something
which has been absolutely fundamental to
left-wing politics and it's had to be
extracted painfully out of the cold dead
hands
those who denied freedom to the great
majority because Democratic freedom role
would lead to economic freedom and this
is something that they didn't want to
give up at all
and so the whole idea that the
Conservative Party exists only or rather
conservative politics right-wing
politics exists only to to contain the
left and have no politics of its own
that's it's innocent victim this lamb to
the slaughter which simply has to try to
keep the Wolves of socialism at bay not
that I think there's anything right
about right about sheep or wrong about
wolves this is just pure mythology is up
there with his tea and sympathy and his
monarchy and mystification which is the
great sort of mist which the
Conservatives try to throw around
politics so that we don't actually
penetrate to the heart of it and see
what's really going on this whole notion
that it's the left trying to rip down
the nation-state while the light is
trying to preserve it sorry who are the
ones talking about rolling back the
state who are the ones talking about
shrinking the state who are the ones
like can Liam Fox for example doing
under the table deals with the with the
US corporations in order to undermine
parliamentary sovereignty and the
legitimacy of the state these people are
not on the Left sure the left are some
bad stuff low every stupid to deny it
but the idea that the right is this
passive mass just quietly trying to keep
things nice and to hold those vicious
left wingers at bay and not do anything
on its own account in terms of
developing its own politics is pure
mythology
I'm keen to take more questions but as
Stella has arrived I think we should
give her the opportunity to speak for
the motion
welcome Stella Creasy labour MP for
Walthamstow recently one backbencher of
the Year award at the 2017 spectator
parliamentarian of the area it can only
go downhill from here
Thank You comrades it's worth a shot
I know it can be hard right now to feel
any excitement any confidence in
politics truth is people have never
trusted people in my job or or kwazii's
job I'm sure quasi both are crazy I were
elected in 2010 after the election
expenses but I'm pretty sure that both
of us we go into a pub someone will say
is that on my tab or my tab to you but
now they fear that even if they could
trust you could you actually do anything
at all it's not just are you all the
same but is there really any point three
words to make people feel pessimistic
about the future of the world
president Donald Trump four words to
make you fearful for what role Britain
is playing foreign secretary Boris
Johnson
eight words as to why am I believe you
should commit to the left we achieve
more together than we do alone that is
why I got involved in the labor movement
now for avoidance of doubts in this
current environment I agree there are
many challenges both within my political
party we do have a problem with
anti-semitism we do have a problem with
misogyny there are also many problems
around the world with organizations and
countries that claim to be left-wing and
are totalitarian there is nothing left
wing about locking up your opponents
there is nothing left wing about
promoting equality at home and ignoring
oppression abroad but there is also
nothing left-wing about going on a
protest and having a hashtag it's what
you do that embodies your valleys and
for me I became a Labour MP because I
believe somewhere in my community and
Walthamstow or God's own country as I
like to call it there are there is a
young person who could cure cancer
if only they had the right opportunities
to be able to realize their potential
and how that would change all of our
lives and frankly I'm not being just
optimistic I mean it's not just that
Walthamstow gave you the musical genius
of Brian Harvey or the footballing
prowess of Harry Kane we gave you to
play a role in Walthamstow as invented
and rexrode as son Andrews in Wilson
Stowe we also and I can see there are
some children here but I hope you
forgive me we gave you Jurek's and
rubber gloves with a London rubber
company and we trained a young man
called Johnny Ives which if you have an
iPad or an iPhone you'll know he
invented both with Apple so I know when
you leave here this evening
something made or invented in
Walthamstow may well continue to
entertain you but that's the point not
everybody in this country has that
opportunity not everybody in your
country has the pathway to realize their
potential and then we all miss out
and left-wing politics for me is about
that simple but powerful principle that
we work together to get the best out of
each of us for the benefit of us all and
when I look at the balance sheet of what
left-wing and right-wing governments
have done in this country I see that
case is compelling
I see the contrast between section 28
and the equalities act between the
internal markets in health care and the
NHS between the Dobbs amendment and
closing our borders to children living
in mud in Calais who have the rights to
be in this country at every turn it has
been when the left and left-wing people
not necessary left-wing parties have
stood up for that principle that
progress has been made in this country
and crucially we have all benefited from
it there is a cold hard economic
arguments at the heart of this equality
is good for everyone
countries that are more equal are more
prosperous more diverse more resilient
and when we look at the world facing us
never more have we needed the left a
world in which Google Apple and Facebook
have a combined wealth of the same of
this country major corporations who have
more power to change your lives and show
your options than the people you elect I
am here I am left wing because I do not
believe that people should be a subset
of markets as the right do I believe
that people should be masters of their
own future and that that true freedom
that Kwazii and Roger I'm no doubt have
told you they want doesn't come from
facing these challenges on your own but
facing them together but individually no
matter how wealthy you may become you
will only ever make limited choices but
if we pool our resources if we share our
values if we commit to that principle of
equality then we can transform
everyone's life and that to me is truly
what being right is
as nie Bevan once said never doubt the
power of decent folk to want to do the
right thing if there isn't a better
example of what being left-wing is I
don't know it thank you
sella crazy thank you very much indeed
let's return to questions from the floor
okay so we've got the the usher up there
number four thank you
well much of georgia's analysis of
history is demonstrably false there was
one particular point that he made that
is absolutely relevant and remained
unanswered
by Roger and that is the point about
wealth inequality and history does show
that wealth inequality as it increases
it does destabilize society sometimes
catastrophic Lee and this is a point
that the right have not really
adequately addressed and I'd really
appreciate it
if Roger and quasi could address that
point thank you a couple more let's go
down number two if you're just the lady
there just to your right who's got her
hand up there perfect hi I would like to
address the whole panel I have a son in
a comp he's 16 and he is doing the thing
that 16 year olds do and it's
challenging they accepted mode of
thought and because he is right-wing he
is being excluded by his friends he's
being judged I I don't see the tolerance
that you talk about being accepted in
just a North London schools it's not
just universities and that's what I used
to do at 16 only I was going the
opposite way because that's what you did
thank you very much and one more perhaps
there in the middle lady with the blonde
hairs got her yep Stella you talked
about equality but I think those on the
right believe in equality of opportunity
we can't all be equal but if we all have
the opportunity to achieve our potential
isn't isn't that the right way to go
about things rather than think we're all
equal and bring everyone down to that
lower lowest common denominator thank
you very much ok let's sir let's turn to
the panel now then Roger do you want to
take that first one on on board the the
the destabilizing to society that wealth
inequality does I think this is a very
powerful point I can't
and George expressed it very well the
argument put forward by Thomas Piketty
he has had huge influence because in
fact it's just common sense you know you
only yeah you only invest if the rate of
return on capital exceeds them you know
the level of economic growth so there is
some there is a kind of April right
truth about this my own view is that
it's not the this inequality does not
matter as long as institutions are in
place which control how that wealth is
used prevent it from being used to set
up private sovereignty over the rest of
us and ensure that it eventually is
spent and passed on and in fact Piketty
took the statistics of all the top
people in Forbes list of super super
rich people one year and said you know
the the wealth is concentrated in their
hands and Anders in the next year
there's even more wealth concentrated in
their hands at the top 10% or whatever
it was but they were completely
different people
and this suggests that after all the
wealth ISM is going around and round as
it should be
creating whatever wealth creates wealth
in itself of course is a static thing
what it what we want is that well to be
spent and have you spent on others I
it's interesting that you say that it's
a strong point I wonder why then you you
are unable to move on to the next stage
which is to say well let's try
redistribution let's try higher taxes
accreditor in order to yes you're
speaking on behalf of this gentleman in
the audience here I would say yes of
course it's no part of being the kind of
conservative I am that you should just
allow these things to to go on
especially if their destabilizing you've
got to find a policy to rectify it
I don't think that the massive taxation
that Piketty recommends will rectify it
indeed he just has led to the to the
transfer of the wealth of France to
London well I think that first of all
you've got to have very strong
insistence that this wealth cannot be
used simply to set up systems of
sovereignty when we're seeing that
emerging with Facebook a kind of
sovereignty over ordinary people a
control of what of opinion what I would
say that you you have to have
regulations about about enforcing free
freedom of speech on the on the how does
that deal with inequality well isn't I'm
not saying that inequalities in itself
is bad I would want to say this isn't
written on circulation the non
circulation of capital is bad but you
just admitted that it is I mean you just
said wealth inequality is destabilizing
there is a problem with it the only
solution you can come up with is freedom
of speech no I don't see that as being a
very effective solution to wealth and
equality while marvelous as it is an
important it is it doesn't actually
address the problem but it is not wealth
inequality which i think is
destabilizing it's the accumulation in
in a small class of people from whom it
doesn't move on if that class is itself
mobile as it is then then I don't see
why it is disabled it's all your
evidence here you cite the Forbes top
ten well yes sometimes Carlos Slim is
below Bill Gates and sometimes Bill
Gates is above Scotland is below that
Carlos Slim that does not reflect the
redistribution of wealth across the size
of course so how would you redistribute
it I think the the issue that people
have certainly in my constituency and I
imagine in Stellar's as well is not so
much with inequality they don't like
inequality but the issue they have and
they're more obsessed with its fairness
and I think the problem that we've had
since the financial crisis of 2008 is
this idea that people were getting away
with it that they were wrecking and
destabilizing a system and they simply
haven't
paid for their recklessness I mean it's
striking in Britain and I'm speaking off
piste I'm not speaking as a Conservative
MP but it's striking that nobody has
actually gone to jail throughout this
whole process and people were hugely
bailed out they their recklessness was
was kind of rewarded and I think the
public generally feel that there's a
real issue about fairness and people
actually being responsible and being
held to account for amassing wealth in
in sometimes nefarious ways and I think
this issue of fairness this issue of
criminal liability this issue of crony
capitalism which hasn't featured in this
debate I think that's a very live issue
and I think people on the right people
who broadly support a liberal economy as
I would describe it need to focus on
crony capitalism we need to not bail out
every financial institution at the drop
of a hat we need to look and tighten up
a criminal law when people are
defrauding the system we need to
actually look at tax evasion and I think
the government I sound like a government
MP but the government actually has done
quite a bit on the issues regarding tax
evasion so I think that's definitely a
point about fairness and and about the
idea of people getting away with it but
what I don't like and I think Stella put
the case very well but she came up with
this phrase equality is good for
everyone I honestly thought that was
from an animal farm or something I mean
it literally I mean it sounds like it's
come straight out of an Orwellian novel
and and and I think one of the people in
the panel in the in the audience made
the very good point we want equality of
opportunity but you're never going to
get absolute equality of outcome and I
suggest the world in which you did get
that would be a pretty grave oaring and
intolerant place and I think that you
know we've got to consider that as part
of your as part of your response Stella
sake
it's fun being lectured by quasi say
when we've been in the chamber today
debating exactly these issues me in the
PFI companies who are bleeding dry our
schools and hospitals and quasi and his
government defending the 190 million
pounds in windfall profits that they've
made from your schools and hospitals me
standing up for the importance of gender
impact assessments so that we can
understand the impact of government
policy in tackling discrimination in our
society government MPs saying that
that's all to do with experts and
academics and we don't want them
involved in our political process I
think what we need here is better
definitions what we mean by equality and
what it represents so madam for me at
what the case for equality represents is
about lost potential so actually the
reason why it matters to have data the
reason why it matters to have a
definition of what a more equal society
looks like is then you can test whether
you're reaching it I have to say Roger
if you lived in my part of the world if
you saw some of the challenges that some
of the poorest people in our society are
dealing with you wouldn't say that
inequality doesn't matter it absolutely
matters
[Applause]
the reason that it matters for all of us
and the reason why we do benefit when we
strive for a more equal society and
therefore strive not just for a general
sense of equality of opportunity but
actually look at the outcomes and ask
are we reaching it is because when I
talk about the talent in my community
it's still the exception rather than the
rule that it will be realized so we are
still missing out on those future cancer
surgeons those feature inventors those
future musicians that could come from
areas of our country where inequality is
ingrained the flipside to that is what
Raj is talking about in terms of people
with high levels of wealth and for me
that's a question of accountability and
it's accountability for the fact that we
all benefit when we make progress so it
is right that all of us make a
contribution to making forward making
that happen and what we see with the PFI
companies with crony capitalism is
organizations not pulling their weight
and then asking people in the poorest
communities of our society to do a
double shift that is why the right will
always fail you because it will ask the
market to figure that question out
rather than asking people and asking
whether people have the power to achieve
their potential madam you talked about
tolerance your apps that you write it is
not left-wing to deny debate the best
policy is the best answers the best
solutions come from debate and discourse
whenever I hear quasi and his friends
talking in Parliament I know the ideas
are better on the left but hang on just
one second silly you didn't really
respond to what the the lady with the 16
year old was saying she's talking very
much about the culture in which case
then that totalitarian isn't that idea
that debate is somehow a bad thing that
yes if you disagree with somebody you
are either a red Tory or a Corbin Easter
or goodness god forbid a Tory MP is
wrong i I want to win arguments by the
power of the ideas that I stand for by
the values that have driven me in
politics I don't want to win them by
intimidating people or excluding people
so I'm genuinely sorry that's happening
to your son if you live in Walthamstow I
would be happy to follow that up with
the school because it is wrong because
actually for your son to be able to
debate ideas just as you did that's why
diversity matters you don't get that if
you look for general equality of
opportunity you don't understand
diversity improves everybody's lives
because you don't get the cut and flow
of the debate I guess I wonder if I can
just put the same question to George
then because it came up when Roger was
talking about the dominance of the left
in institutions and how in at university
level and and the the woman they're
talking about her son at school saying
that you know we're talking about a
cultural issue where the the left is
showing itself to be intolerant I wonder
if you can just address that again I've
got no truck with intolerance at all and
I think it's absolutely essential that
we have debate everywhere and as wide as
possible but actually I wrote down what
Roger said about universities as the
students there they said people in the
university are protected from economic
forces try telling that to students with
40,000 pounds of debt what we see
happening at universities and indeed at
schools is the penetration of this whole
market business ethos neoliberalism the
word they don't like to use and don't
like to hear but the penetration of that
ethos into these institutions which then
actually greatly inhibits people's
freedom it inhibits your freedom to play
to explore to develop ideas because
you've got this debt ticking away in the
background all the time clocking up
clocking up so you have to keep your
head down make sure you get a job which
is going to pay a lot of money when you
get out otherwise that debts just going
to be looming behind you all the time
now this I would say is a great
inhibitor of freedom it's a great
inhibitor of that experimental nature
that should be at the heart of all
education because you're just being
processed into the Machine by this crazy
policy of lumbering young people with
these hideous levels of debt now that's
a right-wing policy that's not a
left-wing policy and that's something
which if young people have to have any
chance of a decent life and bright
prospects we have to get rid of and
straight away thank you very much Rick
we're gonna have to we're gonna have to
just pause for a moment because we would
like the vote to take place again now
if you could use your slips to make a
decision so I'm going to invite the
speakers up now to sum up their speeches
two minutes each and I'm not sure which
order we go in now because we we start
with well we start we start with stellar
we've talked a bit this evening and I
apologize for being late about equality
equality needs to be broken down into
what do we actually mean so yes it means
unequal say it means democracy but it
also means equal access and in one of
the things that we know is dividing our
country right now is the difference
between access to the bank of mum and
dad that isn't about going to university
that's about some very basic things
about children being able to eat have a
roof above their head to be able to deal
with the differences that happen in life
one of the things that being an
egalitarian being left-wing is about is
recognizing how we will solve those
challenges we are Lund likely to be able
to solve them on our own and therefore
we will always end up paying the price
for that failure what the right would
call market failure for the people who
do not achieve their potential who are
not able to contribute to society who
are not able to be in a room with you
and inspire you on to achieve great
things to genuinely we achieve more
together than we do alone and whether
that is a slogan that you might put on a
March or a hashtag it's certainly a way
of life that I have found and seen in my
lifetime to have changed this country
for the better I'm yet to see the same
force for good on the right the left is
not perfect the left has many challenges
but that's one of my predecessors
Clement Lee used to say the left is what
its members make it so I hope tonight
you will join the call to make Britain a
better place
Stella Creasy thank you very much cause
e-tank to start my concluding remarks by
telling an anecdote a friend of mine who
is about to have a baby and is a
momentum activist asked me what I was up
to this week and I said I would be
having a debate about the left and the
right and she said who were the other
speakers and I said she's a momentum
activist she spent the whole of the last
summer trying to get labor and momentum
going in the election and I said Stella
Creasy is my opponent said Stella Creasy
she's not left wing and and listening to
her listening to her I agreed with lots
of what she said of course I want people
in her constituency just as I want
people in Spelthorne to have the massive
opportunities I completely agree with
her when she says that there are too
many people in this country who have the
talent but are not being allowed to
develop that talent through lack of
opportunities and that's exactly why I
went into politics and I think that the
right rather than the left has a much
more robust approach about trying to
unlock talent than the left I mean take
one example in terms of selective
education Stella I know benefited from a
highly selective School in colchester as
many as as many and and might my guilty
secret is that I was at college with
your brother I was a college with your
brother at university and he went to the
boys equivalent and that's a great
school and yet people on the left and
maybe not Stella for people on the left
who've benefited from selective
education have consistently denied it to
lots and lots of people who would have
benefited from it who would have
benefited from and
and so that was just one example that is
just one example of the way I think the
left actually deny and frustrate talent
in a way that I think that people on the
right can can actually try and solve
those sort of problems I'm not saying
the right is perfect I think Stella's
absolutely right there are lots of blame
there's lots of inadequacy on both sides
but I think the general broad approach
is much better on the right on these
issues and I'm delighted actually that
that Stella Stella came tonight the
other thing I would say just in my
closing remarks and she said so who's
the other Chad who she assumed it was a
man I don't know why but she maybe she
had pre knowledge and and she said and I
said Oh George Monbiot and she said ah
he's one of us he's a real lefty so that
was so that was the and and I think I
didn't hear what George said I've heard
is intermittent remarks and I think her
assessment was probably right so I'll
leave it there
Roger Scruton to you yes
what stairs said something quite
important when she said that the left is
what its members make it and this is her
message of hope and kind of triumphalist
message I think the same is true of the
right the right is what its members make
it and they make his in a different way
what I was trying to say was that we
don't actually make it through these
movements like momentum and so on we're
not though fists clenching type we do
nevertheless make it through civil
Association through our belief in and
love for the the country that is ours
and I desire to protect the freedoms
that have grown in it and of course
there are all kinds of things wrong with
it
human beings are imperfect but what we
most of all need as the institutions
that enable us to correct our faults
that's what we're talking about now how
do we correct those faults as they arise
we don't do it by imposing some uniform
egalitarian socialist system from on
high we do it by creating the
opportunities for people to come out and
express their talents and also to
associate with each other in a legal and
a law-abiding and peaceable way and
that's what we've enjoyed in this
country and not everybody in fact very
few countries in the world have enjoyed
it
certainly not in previous centuries
Estela is quite right in emphasizing the
idea of equality is fundamental to the
left-wing vision but I think there's a
tendency to confuse equality and the
pursuit of equality with the pursuit of
wealth that's to say to the elimination
of poverty I live in a very poor
community a community of small farmers
who have 40 or 50 acres each who are
essentially in a subsistence level and
they are all equal in the sense that
they haven't their assets are very small
but nevertheless thanks to country and
the people around them all kinds of
opportunities are constantly arising and
many people take them younger people
take them
take them by moving away from the farm
by by turning their farm into something
like a semi legal haulage business and
so on those are the kind of things that
we we actually that is the way that the
rural economy works the right so it's a
black economy because of course the
government has always stepped on it and
I think this is something that we have
to remember I'm a grammar school boy
like Stella I didn't have the those I
didn't have those privileges well I'm
taking the offer quality is my authority
for this but I was lucky I escaped I
escaped from a poor background was given
all the opportunities that enabled me to
get to Cambridge and become a university
professor later to go around his posh
public schools giving lectures to boys
like Kwazii who emerged to act when I
first met him emerge from the throng
with the coffee of my book on Kant and
asked me to sign it I thought this man's
going to go somewhere you know and he
did the fact is we've what in this
country have enjoyed many of these
equalities opportunities and we've all
all of us left and right have wanted an
equality of opportunity it's just that
we disagree about the means to obtaining
it we on the right think you obtain it
through the the long process of
civilized association whereby people
accommodate to each other and overcome
their problems in their local
communities and their little platoons
those on the left think you've got to
have a statewide system in order to
rectify they're embedded in justices
that we've inherited which George gave
us such a poetic account of at the
beginning so I think that by and large I
would say the rights like the left is
what its members make it and we've made
it something durable and good
Roger Scruton thank you very much and
the last speaker George Monbiot please
just to sum up for the motion sure I
should point out instead of behalf that
she's know the grammar school Nora boy
just to clarify that that's slightly
inaccurate summary there I think the key
to this whole debate is the term social
mobility because I think it's the one
thing we all agree on we all agree that
social mobility is a good thing in fact
Roger and quasi have talked about hardly
anything else fine we all agree that
it's a good thing which causes a real
problem for them because all the data
shows that in conditions of high
inequality you have very low social
mobility and the more the concentration
of wealth by the rich people in society
the lower social mobility becomes when
you have a distributive economy when you
have high taxation on wealth when you
have high spending on public services
high spending by the state in other
words social mobility soars the data is
rock solid on this so if you want social
mobility which we all want you should be
on the left and I welcome these two new
converts
and I think for me you know that the
crucial moment was you know when Roger
admitted that inequality was a bad thing
because of its destabilizing nature but
then the only solution he could propose
to that from the right was freedom of
speech and much as we all agree that
freedom of speech is a wonderful and
necessary an essential thing and can and
should be supported by all sides of the
political debate let me explain the it
is not going to solve inequality not by
itself you need government actions you
need taxation you need public spending
you need social mobility and this ladies
and gentlemen is what the Left offers
and why it has right on its side thank
you
George [ __ ] thank you very much indeed
so we have the result of the vote just
to remind you before the debate you all
voted as you came in a reminder that the
motion tonight was the left has right on
its side before the debate 37 percent
voted against 32 percent voted for and
31 percent were undecided and you've
just voted again after having heard all
four speakers 57 percent voted against
36 percent voted for 6 percent undecided
and it was an 8 percent swing vote
it only remains now for me to say thank
you to all the speakers Stella Creasy
George mom Bo Kwasi parting and Roger
Scruton
I'd also like to thank intelligence
squared and all of you for taking part
and being here tonight thanks very much
for coming
[Applause]